>> Tita Chico: Thank
you very much.
And thank you very
much Laurence,
you know, for welcoming me.
I have, over the years,
really enjoyed the talks
that I've attended here
and it's very special to be
at the Library of Congress
to share some of my thoughts
and work from my new book, which
I love, which I absolutely love.
So, I've been told that
I need to stay here.
I normally tend to walk around.
But, I will, I will stay put
to have my words captured
by the microphone, all right.
Thank you.
So, to begin with
the obvious question.
What do science and seduction
have to do with each other.
Eliza Haywood 1719
seduction novel,
Love In Excess provides
an answer.
The character, the Matchless
Melliora mingles grief
for her father's death with
sexual desire for her guardian,
who is married, and,
with a degree
of self-awareness concludes that
her guardian is an object not
to be safely gazed at.
Her guardian, Count
D'elmont, has a bitter fight
with his wife and, afterwards,
encounters Melliora reading.
He finds her beautiful
and alluring, as you see,
lying on a green bank in a
melancholy but charming posture,
so completely engrossed
in reading
that she saw not the Count
till he was close enough to her
to discern what was the
subject of her entertainment.
D'elmont manages
Melliora's reading
as an occasion for flattery.
And, he compliments her.
These compliments results in
their first sexual encounter.
The inaugural moment,
in the novel,
when they act upon
their mutual desire.
And, there's an edition,
a wonderful first edition
of the novel over on the side.
So, what is Melliora reading
with such focus and commitment
and which makes her look
so alluring and beautiful?
A Volume of Philosophy by
Monsieur Le Fontenelle.
The work for which Fontenelle
was most famous was a volume
explicating Copernican
and Cartesian cosmology,
with Fontenelle on her lap,
D'elmont sees love
in Melliora's eyes.
Now, Haywood's reference
to Fontenelle transpires
within a an establish tradition
of figurative associations
that couple sexual seductions
with scientific knowledge.
Natural philosophy texts,
beginning with Francis Bacon,
frequently presents
scientific practices
as heteronormative
neurotic quests.
Consider Bacon's metaphors
which expressly identify
the early scientists
as a masculine seducer.
The naturalists,
according to Bacon,
wants to penetrate the
inner, into the inner
and further recesses of nature
and to find a way, at length,
into her inner chambers.
If the natural philosopher
seduces, then, nature submits.
It is no wonder if nature
will not give herself
into their hands.
When Bacon's writings
represent nature as female,
the imagine that scientific
scrutiny is both a form
of sexual analysis and
an occasion for conquest
and containment by the
masculinized naturalists.
Within the rational
of draconianism,
sexual effective relations
permit the practice of science
and the production of
scientific knowledge.
Abraham Cowley Ode Upon
Doctor Harvey from 1657,
describes Harvey's discoveries
about the circulation
of blood and, in so
doing, presents nature
as a coil virgin who,
when Harvey's violent passion
she did see began to tremble
and to flee while
he pursues her.
My topic today concerns
seduction plots
and texts devoted to
teaching scientific ideas.
For they picture characters
undergoing an intellectual
conversion to its principles.
And, my focus is on two
dialogues translated
into English from
French and Italian.
Fontenelle's study of Copernican
and Cartesian cosmology
from 1686 and Francesco
Algarotti's rendering
of Newtonian optics in 1737.
So first Fontenelle.
Bernard Le Bovier de
Fontenelle was a major figure
of the French Enlightenment
for the duration
of his long nearly
100 years of his life.
In 1686, he published
his most famous work,
Entretiens sur la pluralite
des mondes, an explication
of Copernican and
Cartesian cosmology.
It was, in France, an
instant best seller resulting
in 4 editions in 3 years
and 33 more editions
up to the author's
death in 1757.
And, a sign of his influence and
his radicalism, it was placed
on the Papel Index
[assumed spelling] in 1687.
and Fontenelle was elected
to the french Academy
in shortly thereafter.
In 1697, he began
his appointment
as Perpetual Secretary of
the Academy of Sciences
which he held unto 1740.
He was, in short, a gatekeeper
of French science studies.
Now, Fontenelle uses dialogue
to challenge Heliocentrism.
This is the belief
held by the character
of the Martianess
[assumed spelling]
when she first meets
the philosopher,
her interlocutor
in the dialogue.
Fontenelle's lady is of a
superior rank to her tutor.
And, Algarotti follows
this example.
Throughout the pages
of the discovery,
the philosopher teaches
the Martianess
about Copernican cosmology
and Cartesian physics,
specifically the theory of
Fortesis [assumed spelling].
In the Cartesian understanding,
particles are always in motion
and always in contact with
each other each spinning
like a planet.
Decartes' Vortices were
disproved by Newton's theory
of gravity the year
after Fontenelle
published the Discovery.
But, Cartesian physics remained
intellectually plausible
for the next 50 years.
And, this is something
that I always want
to underscore with may students.
Even though a theory may have
been disproven immediately,
the original theory continues
to linger and seem plausible.
You don't have historical
change overnight.
And, Fontenelle, himself,
expresses admiration for Newton
but he was not convinced by him.
Now, the genre that
Fontenelle chooses is important.
It's a dialogue between a
philosopher and a noble woman
which allows for, in
Fontenelle's words,
liberty of natural conversation.
The dialogue's dialectic quality
enacts the process of learning.
Making mistakes and having them
corrected is part of learning.
It's not an occasion
to abandon the inquiry.
The French Salon culture,
in which powerful women
were active leaders,
was especially amendable to
these sorts of conversations.
Fontenelle's was a world
organized by elaborate rules
of social etiquette, practices
that reflected the ideals
of lightness, gallantry
and gallantry.
These social norms shaped some
of the earliest reputations
of enlighten philosophers.
All of this gets incorporated
into how Fontenelle
imagines the conversation
between the noble
woman and her tutor.
Within the dialogue, Fontenelle
eludes to the genre of romance,
a reference that has the effect
of easing the dialogue's
conjunction
of science and seduction.
In his preference, he explains,
I'm going to give
you a long quotation.
He writes, it is not to
penetrate by force of mediation
into a thing that's obscure
in itself or anything
that is obscurely explained, tis
only to read and to represent
to yourselves at the same what
you read and to form some image
of it that may be clear and free
from perplexing difficulties.
I ask of the ladies, for this
system, that the same attention
that they must give
the Princess of Cleves,
if they would follow
the intrigue and find
out the beauties of it.
Though, the truth is that the
ideas of this book are not
so familiar to the most
part of ladies as those
of the Princess of Cleves.
But, they are not more obscure
than those of that novel,
and yet, they need not
think above twice at most.
And, they will be capable
of taking a true measure
and having a just
sense of the whole.
Now, to set back for a
moment, Fontenelle's point is
that reading about Natural
philosophy, beginners reading
about natural philosophy is
just as foreign as reading
about love affair in the
16th century French court.
With this illusion to
Madame de Lafayette's novel,
Fontenelle enjoys his readers
to interpret the discovery
as though they were attending to
the detailed nuances and turns
of seduction narrative.
Such reading is an
active engagement
in the process of
representation.
Near the conclusion
of the discovery,
the Martianess reflects
upon the effect
of the scientific education
on her sense of self.
She says I find the
worlds, the heavens,
and the celestial bodies,
so subject to change
that I am altogether
returned to myself.
This return to myself is
not an attempt to reject
or renounce the self-subjective
bias, but, to welcome it.
Learning requires the
ability, in Fontenelle's words,
to represent to yourselves
at the same what you read,
to form some image of it
and maybe clear and free.
In the Lochian Lexicon
[assumed spelling],
this is the imagination
which fiction writers
in the 18th century
understood as enabling learning
through fiction and feeling.
Fontenelle insists that a
good reader is a good learner.
And, this individual actively
engages the imagination
to apprehend new ideas,
concepts, and materials.
Anyone conversant in
the language of romance,
such as La Princess de
Cleves, is equally capable
of using her attention
and imagination
to understand Copernicus
and Decartes.
Now, the genre of romance
has long been associated
with absorptive reading,
beginning with William
Congreve's preface in 1692
to Incognita in which he
declares that romance elevates
and surprises the reader
into a giddy delight.
Scholars often oppose
the romance
to the novel stipulating
the former is infatuated
with the extraordinary,
the latter with the real.
So, this idea that romance
really is talking about things
that could not possibly be,
it's fantasy, extraordinary,
and the novel is grounded
I a notion of realism.
Within this critical tradition,
romance pertains to things
that are un-observable
that can never be observed.
And, it's a classic description
that refuses experimental
verification.
So, that's a kind of
truism in the field.
So, what I want to point
out is that none other
than Robert Boyle is a founding
member of the Royal Society,
a father of chemistry, and
an extraordinary scientist.
None other than Robert Boyle
challenged the perception
that romance exclusively obtains
to unverifiable experience.
Among his many intellectual
pursuits,
Boyle pondered the principles of
romance and natural philosophy,
the purportedly antithetical
realms
of the imaginative
and the observable.
He offered a text,
it's now lost,
but it called Apology
for Romances.
He also published
his own romance
which he panned as a young man.
In a text that he published
in 1671, the Excellency
of Theology Compared
with Natural Philosophy,
Boyle makes a comparison
similar to the one
that Fontenelle makes
in preface.
The experience of
nature and romances,
Boyle argues, is analogical.
In the Book of Nature, as
in a well contrived romance,
the parts have such a connection
in relation to one another
and the things we would
discover are darkly
or incompletely knowable
by those that perceive them
that the mind is never
satisfied till it comes
to the end of the book.
In other words, the intricacy
of the natural world correlates
to that of the romance world.
The connection supposes, though
it does not fully depict,
a philosopher and a
reader who share the skill
of careful observation.
Romance may induce an absorptive
reader, but it also primes
that reader to perceive
the meaningful data
of the natural world.
Now, Fontenelle's choice
of La Princess de Cleves,
as an intellectual model,
also establishes an early link
to the seduction plot.
La Princess de Cleves
is a seduction story
that follows the effective
tangle of the married woman
and a nobleman, the
narrative trajectory
and the educational imperative
in Fontenelle's text require
a conversion to Copernican
and Cartesian principles.
And, Fontenelle understands this
conversion as a seduction story.
In other words, seduction
allows Fontenelle
to take a literary plot and uses
it to narrate how one learns
and comes to believe
natural philosophy.
In the first dialogue,
the Martianess
and the Philosopher enjoy a
walk in the garden after supper
as they discuss the
beauty of the night sky.
It is a time, they determine,
most amenable to lovers.
The philosopher's
description is luxurious.
We have the moon
shining through the trees
that checkers the paths beneath
a most resplendent bite upon
the green.
The stars looked all like pure
polished gold whose luster was
extremely heightened by
the deep assured field
on which they were placed.
When the philosopher praises
the beauty of daytime,
the Martianess turns to
metaphor, day and night as fair
and dark ladies, the
latter of whom are superior.
She also insists that that the
Philosopher agree with her.
Nighttime and dark haired
women produce soft effects
that lead to romance.
She says, as you see,
how comes it that lovers
who are the best judges of
what is pleasing and touching
to always address
themselves to the night
in all their songs and elegies?
Both the Martianess and the
Philosopher become averted
in how daylight obscures
the stars.
The star filled night sky
facilitates or roving fancies
about the universe in a
way that daylight cannot.
Enlightenment occurs in
the absence of the sun.
The Martianess says she has
always felt those effects
of night you tell me, I love the
stars and could be hardly angry
with the sun for taking
them from my sight.
Her sentiment prompts the
Philosopher to explain,
I cannot forgive the sun's
taking from me the sight
of all those worlds
that there are.
With that, the Martianess's
curiosity is peak
and also insatiable.
Worlds, she said, what worlds?
This is the question the
forms the provocation
for the ensuing scientific
dialogue.
The Philosopher immediately
sees the swerve from Romance
to cosmology as a loss
of an opportunity
for sexual seduction.
And, he's afraid he'll
be faulted for this.
He says, oh Madam, I shall
never endure to be reproached
with that neglect of
my own happiness, that,
in a grove at ten o'clock
at night, I talk of nothing
but philosophy to the
greatest beauty in the world.
No Madam, search for
philosophy somewhere else.
He resists, she insists,
and the moment
for seduction seems to be lost.
Astronomy displaces eroticism.
However, rather than abandon
the seductive framework
that he evokes here, Fontenelle,
instead, re-calibrates it.
The garden bathed in moonlight
first allows the Philosopher
to articular his own
double seduction.
He is seduced by the prospect of
other worlds and he is seduced
by the intellectual
desires of the Martianess.
The text explicitly
characterizes the Philosopher
as succumbing to the
Martianess's seduction.
He says, but twas in vain
to put here off by excuses.
From a novelty she was already
but too much pre-possesed with.
He says there was a necessity of
yielding and all I could do was
to prevail with her to be secret
for the saving of my honor.
Cosmology and the
Martianess are both alluring.
They both seduce
the Philosopher.
He capitulates the desires
for the language of surrender.
I found myself engaged
past retreat.
Such enjoinder, such resignation
could easily be transported
from the voice of
the desperate heroine
in a seduction narrative.
Now, even if one is tempted
to dismiss this opening scene,
which really precipitates
the entire dialogue,
as merely a contrivance.
Fontenelle returns
to the same process
of seduction on the fifth night.
At this point, the Martianess
and the Philosopher
are discussing those
Cartesian Vortices.
The topic supplies fanciable
and humorous [inaudible].
The Martianess says,
for example,
let my brains turn round
if they will as if you're
on a spinning world and
everything about us is spinning.
Amidst this conversation,
the Philosopher confess
that his one distemper is love.
They, wherein the turbilones
[assumed spelling] are not
concerned at all.
An infinite multitude of other
worlds may render little this
in your esteem, but they do not
spoil fine eyes, a pretty mouth,
or make the charms
of whit ever less.
These will still have their
true values, still bear a price
in spite of all the
worlds and universe.
So, what he's saying is that,
in spite of all the
astronomical discoveries
and cosmological discoveries
he might encounter and all
of these discoveries that might
changes one's view of the world,
none of this will challenge
is ideas about love.
The Martianes laughs and
states, love sames himself
from all dangers and
there's no system
or opinion that can hurt him.
Now, the dialogue's
turn to love does more
than offer the Philosopher
and the Martianess an
excuse for reporte.
And, they are endlessly kind
of charming and flirting
with each other in this way.
Falling in love is the
process of giving oneself
over to the possibility
of seduction.
And this acts as a model
of [inaudible] acquisition
within the text.
Scientific education, within
Fontenelle's dialogue,
requires that a learner,
fundamentally, be seduced.
Since we are always in the humor
of mixing some little
gallantries
with the most serious
discourses, give me lead
to tell you that
mathematical reasoning is,
in some things, near
a kin to love.
You cannot allow the smallest
favor to a lover, but,
he will soon persuade
you to yield another,
and after that, a little more.
And, in the end,
prevails entirely.
So, if you grab the least
principles to a mathematician,
he will instantly draw
consequences from it,
which you must yield also, and
from that another, and a third,
and maugre all your
resistance in a short time.
He will lead you so far
that you cannot retreat.
And, this is one of the
most remarkable lines.
These two sorts of men, the
lover and the philosopher,
always take more
than is given them.
Persuasion here is seduction.
Fontenelle's Philosopher
recounts the step
by step process wherein one
figure inculcates another
into a new world view, whether
it concerns amatory relations
or cosmology.
The process of seduction
is inherently social,
whether it is embodied between
two lovers or whether it is
in virtual between a
learned text and a reader.
And, it relies upon
the lure of reading
as one finds oneself swept
up on a rushing current
of proposition after
proposition.
The leading cosmology
results from a series
of actions enacted by another.
Those actions transport
an individual from one set
of beliefs to another, a dynamic
that mimics the narrative
structure of seduction stories.
The conclusion whether
an intellectual
or amatory terms is submission.
While the Philosopher, in the
opening pages, positions himself
as succumbing to the
Martianess's ardent desire
to know about cosmology, he,
here, turns to the Martianess
to tell her you are too
far engaged to retire
and therefore you
must generously yield.
Submission confirms
consent and agreement.
She says, I yield and confess
you overcharge me with worlds
and terbiens [assumed spelling].
She announces her confession.
I am extremely in love with
these ideas you give me.
In Fontenelle's text,
we see the delineation
of scientific education
that draws upon and in
so doing revises
the torpid seduction
so often associated
with sexual coercion.
The setting of nighttime
being bathed
in moonlight could be
seen and generally is seen
as anticipating a
neurotic encounter.
But, it is an equally
appropriate environment
for a discussion of cosmology.
Of course, sex and the cosmos
are never far from each other.
The subject position
that Fontenelle imagines
for his Martianess depends
upon careful observation
and learning.
And, it also depends upon
her willingness and ability
to be seduced into
the Copernican
and Cartesian imaginary.
Now, I want to, the
last portion is
to talk a little bit
briefly about Algarotti.
Francesco Algarotti
published his text,
and I don't have Italian,
but, it's translated
by Elizabeth Carter as Sir Isaac
Newton's Philosophy Explained
for the Use of the Ladies.
He published it in 1737.
The title pages means Naples is
a place of publication, though,
it was printed in Milan under
somewhat covert circumstances.
And I'd love to know more about
this but, it's a murky history.
Newton for the Ladies went
through six Italian editions
in the six years after
its original publication
with ten more by 1812.
And, it was also translated,
as you can imagine,
quickly in the English,
French, Russian, Swedish,
German, and Portuguese.
So, it moved across
national linguistic borders
and it moved across the century.
So, Newton for the Ladies does
not denounce Copernicanism.
And therefore, it, just as
Fontenelle's text was placed
on the Catholic Church's
index of forbidden books.
Also, like his predicessor,
Algarotti uses the genre
of the scientific dialogue.
Algarotti's appropriation
of the seduction plot
demonstrates the persistence
of this plot as a means to
enact scientific education.
The science he teaches
is different.
But Algarotti models
his dialogue explicitly
on Fontenelle's.
At the moment that
the Noble Woman,
insists upon an education,
this time in Newton's theories
of light and color, Algarotti
evokes his predecessor.
In response to the Noble Woman,
the Philosopher begs she would
at least had patience
till evening,
telling her that the night had
always been the time consecrated
to philosophical affairs,
explaining that the
most polite philosopher
in France had made use of it in
a circumstance resembling mine
and made no scruple of
entertaining a fine lady
with philosophical discourses,
and would at midnight.
Yet, Algarotti's Noble
Woman is impatient.
She spoke with this, she spoke
this with an era of authority
that enforced her commands
in the most amiable manner
and made it a pleasure to
obey, says the Philosopher.
The Martianess's refusal here to
accede to the Philosopher desire
to nighttime [inaudible]
reflects her agency
and her greater rank of course
and also has the effect of,
surprise, surprise, increasing
the Philosopher's desire
to be seduced by her
intellectual philosophy.
When the Philosopher fails to
seduce the Martianess sexually,
he finds herself, instead,
seduced by her epistemological
desires.
Philosophers, argues the
Philosopher, are no different
from mistresses, for, both
have the obligation, he says,
to make good on their promises.
A mistresses must accede to
enter into a sexual relation
and a philosopher into
an intellectual one.
But, the pathway of
seduction works both ways.
If the Martianess seduces the
Philosopher with her desire
to return, to learn,
the Newtonianism,
presented by the Philosopher,
in turn, seduces her.
As in Fontenelle,
mathematicians are like lovers.
If what you grant them, at first
be ever so little, they know how
to make so good an
advantage of it
as to lead you insensibly
farther
than you've ever imagined.
Even though the Martianess
demurs, he says,
I have as little skill
in the artifices of love
as in the those of
philosophy and mathematics.
She's enchanted by
and ultimately seduced
by the principles
of Newtonianism.
Her epistemological
craving returns throughout
their dialogues.
She felt, as you see,
the utmost impatience
to be more learned than hugan.
She was not for losing
a moment's time
but would continued our
discourses upon vision the next
morning as soon as
ever we were up.
This was all the
optics she could get
from me in the morning.
Following an extensive
discussion concerning the
refrangibility of light,
the Philosopher responds
to the Martianess in terms
that points to the structure
of desire and to the
plot of seduction.
Tis in philosphy, as in
all other human affairs
where the accomplishment
of one desire often
gives birth to another.
And, you have that same process
that you saw in Fontenelle.
As soon as you learn a little
bit, you want to learn more
and you want to learn more,
it's a structured desire.
So, the female reader of
Algarotti's text is imagined
as an eager recipient
ready to be swayed
by the seductive allure
of Newtonian science.
She is an effective being.
And, the plot of
seduction is appropriate
because it concerns affect,
namely a subject's heart
rather than her mind.
And, in this way, Algarotti
and Fontenelle are a
little bit different.
Algarotti writes, the marvelous
of which the heart always
desires of being effected is
so fond happily arises in
true philosophy of itself
with out the help of machines.
And then, he asks,
is there anything
in which a writer should omit
any endeavors to move the heart.
So, the role of affect
and seduction introduces the
possibility that the conversion
to Newtonianism may not succeed.
Because, she perceives
rather than understands,
she is effected by and
receives Newtonianism,
the Martianess second
guesses herself.
When they discuss
the refrangibility
of light, she panics.
She asks have I acted
wrong in suffering myself
to be too easily convinced?
The Philosopher assures her that
a lady cannot err in this point.
Uncertainty does not derail
the conversion process.
She says, let me intrigue you
to make me a complete Newtonian.
I plainly see, by my conversion,
I so shall inquire the knowledge
of truth without
losing that pleasure
which I found in being deceived.
And, the end of their six
dialogues accomplishes her
desire for conversion.
If the Martianess is seduced by
the ideas of Newtonianism, then,
she provokes a philosopher
by placing Newton himself
within such a plot.
You seem to represent nature
as a coquette she says,
and Sir Isaac Newton
as a jealous lover
who never thinks
he has proof enough
of the fidelity of his mistress.
The Martianess's portrait of
Newton recalls a scientific
and erotic legacy
of masculinized intellectual
mastery commonly found
in Bacon and his followers.
The process of acquiring
natural philosophical knowledge
that then can be distributed
to alkalies requires endless
experimentation and pursuit.
A single experiment does
not satisfy a philosopher.
The Philosopher answers this
was the only object of his love.
He confirms the legitimacy
and compares them and suggests
that Newton's rightful posture
was of a jealous love driven
to distraction to find out any
and all secrets of
the natural world.
Newton, as a natural
philosopher,
embodies the suspicion
of a controlling lover.
However, Algarotti's Philosopher
presses for a key difference.
So, Newton exhibits
philosophical jealousy.
And this very vividly
binds the seduction revert
to scientific discovery.
Under writing the
process of seduction
that the Philosopher here
and the Martianess undergo,
is a super structure that
understands seduction
as a relation of
power and control.
Newton's knowledge acquisition
does not reside an ecstatic
realm but forcibly
encounters nature, its subject,
and bends nature to its
practitioner's will.
The Philosopher qualifies
the admission
that Newton too has the
desires of a seducer.
At the text's conclusion,
he distinguishes the
Martianess's passions
from Newton's moderation.
So, the Philosopher says, the
moderation of our philosophers
in never affirming
anything to be true
which was not demonstrated
by observation,
may serve for an example
for most rash asserters.
In spite of the Martianess's
enthusiastic response,
the findings of Newton,
insists the Philosopher,
are sober and reasoned.
He says they are not assertions
but they are discoveries.
Now, Algarotti's text we've
witnessed the multi-valient
nature of the seduction paradigm
in ways that accord with
and differ from the
precedent of Fontenelle.
In Fontenelle, the Philosopher
reports the Martianess seduces
him and the Martianess
admits that she is seduced
by her scientific education.
These are moments of learning.
But, Algarotti privileges a
woman's power of perception
over her understanding,
a form of cognition
that excused Fontenelle's
celebration of the imagination
and it presents feeling
as a mode of learning.
Algarotti's texts highlights the
imperative for seduction built
into the project of natural
philosophy as a practice.
And, in this final
seduction, the producer
of knowledge seduces a
vulnerable and feminized nature
in the process of revealing
the gender an sexual politics
of knowing and being known.
To conclude, through their
evocation and adaptation
of the seduction plot, these
scientific dialogues demonstrate
that believing in science
is not merely a matter
of rational understanding.
The idea of virtual
witnessing that is written
into the early scientific
project which is reading
and believing experiments,
establishes textual mediation
as a vital technology
of scientific inquiry.
It ultimately depends up on
readers reading and imagining
and thus corroborating the
accuracy of reported findings.
But, the seduction plot
reveals another technology.
Understood as a transformative
process,
seduction plots move an
individual from one circumstance
or one set of beliefs
to another.
Seduction acts upon the
individuals who experience it.
It pushes one beyond the limits
of rational disbelief or belief
and it exacts submission.
To use the seduction
plot as a model
for scientific education spells
out the conversion one must
undergo, the conversion
to which one must be subjective
to become a modern
enlightened subject.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Anyone have any
questions or any comments?
[ Background noise ]
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> My [inaudible] which around
nature is one of more abuse
and rape than seduction.
Am I misinterpreting?
>> Tita Chico: So, when
I, and I'm speaking here
in the microphone so I.
So the question here is
why Bacon's language seems
to be much more about abuse
and rape rather than seduction?
So, my evocative seduction
draws upon a body of literature
that is looking at seduction
more generally as a continuum,
that rape, that includes rape.
>> Okay.
>> Tita Chico: And so, it
is a taking over of someone
without their consent, okay.
And, definitions of rape in
the 17th and 18th century are
in no way commensurate
with how define it today.
Whether one could be
raped depended upon one's
subject position.
And, it reveals all sorts
of ideology, but, seduction,
more generally and the kind of
moving from rape to marriage,
I'm evoking the work
of Toni Bowers here,
is using the same logic, the
same logic of submission, yeah.
So, thanks for that
question, yeah.
It's very jarring to
our modern eyes, right.
But, I think it's important to
remember that the whole idea
of companion marriage
itself use that same logic.
>> Right.
>> Tita Chico: So, even
institutions and structures
that seem not to be
dependent upon violence
and abuse are inherent,
have that inherent
structure within them.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, so
Toni Bower's work,
the book in particular, it's
called By Force or Fraud,
and she's quoting satan
there, describing, you know,
how shall we take Eden.
Shall we do it by
force or by fraud?
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Several, you know, Fontenelle
and [inaudible] continental.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> And translated by [inaudible]
and Elizabeth Carter.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> And, I'm wondering
what, how do you see,
if you see a cultural
transformation
in continental understandings
in romance
and plot over [inaudible]?
And, why I'm thinking that is
because often there's a sense
that a French example of romance
is so much more psychological.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> Than English, it's more
rooted into a different,
rather than to plot to
scheme they're rooted
into map and actually observe.
And so then, I was
just wondering
if you had done anything
with the the appropriation,
also appropriation and
maybe transformation?
>> Tita Chico: Yeah,
that's a really nice point.
So, the, what I did
not have time to talk
about is the acts
of translation.
So I'm, you know, I'm writing
about the British enlightenment.
And, one of the things I'm
very interested in thinking
about is the porousness
of these [inaudible]
and linguistic borders.
I draw upon the translations
as imagining them as, you know,
this is one of the key ways
that they were available
to the British reading public.
[Inaudible] so first,
a few things,
one translation was a way
that women writers made money,
one of the, and you know,
it was kind of open to them.
And, Elizabeth Carter
made a sizable amount
for her translation
of Algarotti as well
as her other things,
she was very learned.
We don't have as
much of a record
of her imprint in the text.
We do with Alfred Baynes.
A few things, she takes
Fontenelle's name off the title
page and puts hers on there.
She has, right, so claiming
that kind of authority.
She also has an extended
treatise about translation,
and the, within that,
she makes a number
of scientific arguments
discounting
Fontenelle's science.
So, she's putting her mark
as a scientific expert
through the process
of translation.
So, the second, the next
thing I would say is
that I chose her translation
for a number of reasons.
There were other, you
know, Glanvill Fellow
of the Royal Society and
there was an Irish translation
that was immediate.
And, those are very, you know,
they take the French references
and they make them English,
you know, very explicitly,
not nationalist, but make
them very, particularly
with Glanvill, and
this becomes a way
of pumping up the Royal Society.
What Baynes is interested in,
because she has the variety
of writing, kind of,
and experienced writing,
why I find her translation
so much more interesting is
she focuses in on this quality
of fancy that is
absolutely central
to my reading of the romance.
So, this is to get to your other
question about or your question
about the mobility of
the seduction plot.
And so, Fontenelle is
using this idea, he evokes,
she translates it as fancy.
That fancy is an
intellectual technology.
And, that becomes a kind of
gateway to think about what,
in my larger work,
I call literariness.
So, that's literary knowledge,
the fancy comes away to think
about literary knowledge.
I think your point
about seduction being
intellectual versus, you know,
if you just compare the 17th
century tradition between France
and Britain, I mean,
in the 17th century,
late 17th century English
edition, it's violence.
These are, it is, it's
rapes, its constant kind
of physical sexual assaults.
And, that is so called
seduction, right,
versus the psychological, right.
So, I think that's a nice
point to keep in mind.
And so, there's a kind of
importation that seduction has
to do with sex and bodies,
but, it also has this other way
of working intellectually, yeah.
And, I think that's way
it's such a productive plot
and narrative trajectory
for thinking about the world
in a radically new way, yeah,
that challenges everything
you've ever thought of.
And, how do you come
to believe that?
Yeah. Yeah.
>> I have a connection that men
in early modern society only
know how to [inaudible].
He wants position,
he wants money.
But this is the only language
he knows how to use to approach.
And, I think that
stretches across the period.
So, do you think
that has any barring
on choosing this vocabulary
this paradigm of seduction,
the only way that a male
can approach a female is
in a sexualized context?
>> Tita Chico: That's
an interesting question.
So, that's, these two texts
are designed, they say they're
for women readers and they
imagine the woman, right.
Their readership was
imagined much more broadly.
So the, you know,
Fontenelle imagines,
and he says quite specifically,
I am writing for men and women.
So, in a sense, within
the fiction of it,
she's seduced but, within the
reading practice of discovery,
anyone, it's a subject
position that's open.
It may be feminized, but it's
open to and it's imagined,
Fontenelle imagines through the
Salon culture, right, that men
and women are going to
be reading this and have
that process of learning
science is one of seduction.
And so, this is why you
have the Philosopher
in both texts imagine
being seduce.
And, this is why, so, I agree
with you in a certain way, but,
I think it has a greater
flexibility within the text.
So, there is that
subject position of kind
of imagining a young
woman or, in this case,
it's tricky because
these are women of rank.
>> But they're still women.
>> Tita Chico: They're still
women, they're women of rank,
their tutors are
of a lower rank.
We're at the time where
gender and rank are still,
rank is still, in many
ways, going to trump gender,
not completely, I mean on a
long term feminist scaler.
So, I see what you're saying.
But, I think, one of the
things that I'm interested
in is how this trope comes
to explain and becomes a way
of convincing people
about empiricism.
I think that gets lost in
the history of science,
absolutely gets lost in
the history of science.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
[inaudible] yeah.
So you have, this is also a
world in which what we think now
as the disciplinary knowledge
of science being absolutely
a million miles away
from the disciplinary
knowledge of the humanities,
that disciplinary
difference doesn't exist.
And so, to be learned and
educated, one was fluent
or had some kind of fluency.
So, these texts operating
in that kind
of marketplace as well.
You could buy a ticket
and go see, you know,
Benjamin Martin who, he
has a guide book over there
and it's addressed to
young gentlemen and ladies.
And, the fiction is, it's
a brother coming back
from university teaching
a sister.
But, this was available to
anyone who was, you know,
picking up a novel,
going to the theater,
going to learn a little bit
about [inaudible], yeah.
Yeah.
>> Thanks for a fascinating
talk.
>> Tita Chico: Thank you.
>> My question is do you
think that Fontenelle
and Algarotti here, the primary
motivation is to lay expositions
on [inaudible] or are they
simply printing manuals
for the scientific education?
What is their, you're making
it sound like, you know,
they're really thinking
about this whole,
I just want to understand
[inaudible].
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> Or, are they just trying
to help the [inaudible]
regarding science?
>> Tita Chico: I, they
can, it's [inaudible].
So, to promote the scientific
theories, they have to chart
out how one comes to believe
them because you don't have,
because the information,
in a sense, is so radical.
So, there's no precedent.
It is how do you kind of
radically convince someone
of that, the sun is not
the center of the universe?
And so, when that is such a kind
of experiential diurnal
notion of what the world is.
So, I think that, for
both of them, they're,
the choice of a dialogue
signals right off the bat
that they are interested
in demonstrating the
process of learning, yeah.
And so, that is a
very kind of that back
and forth a bit by bit.
They could've written
it as a treatise,
this is, you know, from start.
There are lots of
different genres
that would've been available.
But, they choose a dialogue
and the choose a
scientific dialogue,
and they choose these
particular characters, yeah.
So, I think you can't, for them,
it's absolutely bound together.
Yeah. Yes hi.
>> Thank you so much
[inaudible].
>> Tita Chico: Okay.
>> I'd like to ask a
question on experiential.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> In terms of [inaudible]
science, there's a lot
of thinking about how
learning or doing, sort of,
the way in which people really
best absorb information.
How does the sort of promoter
being the seduction [inaudible]
because you're devoid
of actually looking
or actually doing so.
>> Tita Chico: Right.
>> I mean like you don't
have the prism, right.
So, how are you understanding
[inaudible],
when you don't have the
telescope to look, [inaudible].
>> Tita Chico: Not, right
not generally yeah, yeah.
Was there more to that?
>> No, no, no, no.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
So, there is, absolutely,
what we think of now
as scientific knowledge
is generated
through artisanal practice.
So, you have Hook and all of
those people doing, you know.
And Ian Hacking talks
about experiment is doing.
So, there is that realm in
which discoveries are made.
I mean, I'm using the
passive [inaudible], right,
which they make discoveries.
The challenge, and this is where
my work is thinking about Shapin
and Schaffer, Leviathan
and the Air-Pump,
but really pushing well beyond.
Because what they
had, what Shapin
and Schaffer have given
us is an understanding
that for scientific
knowledge to be corroborated,
which it always needs to be
corroborated, there are only
so many people who can
look under a microscope.
And, so, they use this idea,
which you might be familiar
with, of virtual witnessing,
which is a, and what they mean
by that is readers
reading the experiment
and imagining that
they can do it.
And that becomes a
mechanism of authorization.
So, you have built in to the way
that early scientific
knowledge is produced,
the experiential
and the literary.
And then literary requires
the imagination of the reader
to visualize something
as plausible.
And that realm of plausibility,
and that realm of imagination,
is, it gets obscured because we
think facts are facts, right?
It gets obscured, but that
is the, that can only happen
through a literary imagination.
So, the step to a
seduction plot is to say,
this is another literary
technology
that accomplishes
the same thing.
And, so, it is, there is also
the, you know, there's the sense
that these things are available.
You can buy a microscope, you
can look through a telescope.
Eliza Haywood's Female
Spectator talks about, you know,
she and her friends go out
to the country, and they look
at all sorts of things
through a microscope,
they go to a neighbor's house
and look through a telescope.
But the, so there are
these moments of praxis.
But, what is absolutely
central are these moments
of representation
of that praxis.
And, so that the, you
know, it's the rule of the,
one of these I'm really
interested in is the role
of the imagination in
empirical knowledge.
And it is, you know, Boyle talks
about this, Hooke, you know,
it's in their own literature,
their own way of understanding.
But, I think, in the history
of science, we've really,
and the kind of triumphalism
that science is objective,
like the history
of objectivity is,
obscures the subjective,
and degrades it.
And, I think that, what I
want to recover is the fact
that it is not degraded,
absolutely central
to the artisanal and
the experiential.
Yeah?
>> I would completely
agree with you.
But, I'm just, I'm wondering
if there's also an assumption
on the part of these male
authors that, I mean,
I guess it's maybe a
gender based argument,
because you find, at least in
the middle of the 18th century,
[inaudible], like this
is for the ladies.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> Sort of water it
down, distill it,
to get ladies to understand.
And it just, [inaudible] when
you look at the manuscript books
of ladies, right, they wall
want to know this information.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> So, they don't need
it to [inaudible].
>> Tita Chico: Right.
>> Majority the same way.
So, I'm just wondering, is
there gender mechanisms?
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> Because I completely think
you're right, [inaudible].
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> And we need that
more [inaudible].
And maybe it takes an
interdisciplinary [inaudible].
>> Tita Chico: Kind
of pulled that out.
So, it's a, one I'm
going to say is a version
of what I was saying to Sabrina.
So, that you do how, you
tete-a-tete, it's such and such
for the ladies, such
and such for the ladies.
[ Background noise ]
It is addressed to this
imagined, ignorant woman.
But, and you know, Alfred
Bayne says, was it [inaudible],
I think they both say,
this is for women,
and men of leisure,
it's for everyone.
But, it gets addressed
as for the ladies.
And, then, if you look at the
readership of these texts, and,
which is a whole other world,
but the readership of it shows
that these are being sold to
gentlemen, like Samuel Pepys.
So, you know, Newton
for the ladies is,
it is now just for women.
You know, Newton, he's
impossible to understand, right?
So, that just becomes, in a
sense, if you want to say,
it's a kind of marketing
technique that actually alludes
to a much broader audience.
And, I would, you know, Bill
Warner makes this argument
about the novel, more
generally, that the, you know,
what we think of as amatory
fiction, and the domestic novel,
that that is, that that kind of,
the idea that that is just
imagining and produced
for a female, young
impressionable female reader,
is historically very misleading.
And it misses the kind of
pleasure of a reader entering
into that space, and that
absorptive reading, itself,
is about being, kind
of, being seduced
and subjective to the text.
But, I think, you know, and if
you start looking at, kind of,
diaries and things like that,
these texts are being pursued
by a much broader category than
just, quote unquote, the ladies.
Yeah.
>> But then [inaudible]
a way which you put it
out there is watered
down for the ladies,
that's really the whole
patriarchal paradigm.
That's reinforcing, right?
>> Tita Chico: Yes.
>> That's reinforcing
male superiority
and female inferiority.
So, there's no reason why
men wouldn't read that.
>> Tita Chico: So, let me
point to a key difference
between Fontenelle and
Algarotti, to get at this.
So, Algarotti has,
he talks about,
I'm going to keep this
simple, I'm not going
to use any of the calculations.
It was also, I mean, Newtonism,
like I said, no one read,
I mean, so, he's already
starting off with, kind of,
making a claim that's ludicrous.
As if she has, kind
of, primary knowledge.
But he said, I'm only going
to take us to the temple door.
And then, Portico, that's
what Newton for the ladies is.
Fontenelle is very different.
Fontenelle says, I am writing
for those who are experts,
as well as the gentlemen and
women who are not experts.
So, this trope, if you
will, can be utilized
in a variety of different ways.
Someone like, and I think it's
really important that someone
like Elizabeth Carter is doing
the translation of Algarotti.
She is the one who
brings Newton home.
She was known, you know,
Samuel Johnson said,
she was smarter than,
the smartest person
he had ever met, okay?
She had a reputation
for learning.
And this was as, weirdly,
the you know, Newton going
through Algoratti
and then coming back
through Carter was how Newton
came to be known mid century on.
And it is through
this incredibly,
incredibly brilliant
learned woman.
So it, yeah, I mean it's,
there's not a clear cut,
and that's why I
think it's important,
we have to keep all
this in mind.
And it's not that anything
written to the ladies imagines,
you know, it's just, kind of,
offensively imagining women
as stupid, or as, kind of,
idealistically imagining women
as all knowing, right,
or intelligent.
But the power of these, I think,
is really important
to keep in mind.
And how it becomes, anyway, so.
[ Background noise ]
>> I think that's interesting
in terms of experiential,
that removed to that,
because that also,
problem [inaudible] is gender.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> In a sense of his experience.
And the idea, too, of
seduction as a tool.
I'm just kind of thinking
of what all of the audience,
and you, had brought out in
this discussion, so it's a,
kind of, comment, here.
But, when we see the effects,
not in romances, but in novels,
of the attention to detail.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> Because of the microscope
and the [inaudible],
the believability of
uncovering what isn't seen,
and making that,
that's different.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> That is, actually,
not metaphoric.
It's a tool for details for
trades, where you're talking
about seduction as a technology
for movement, you know,
rather than one is, I put the,
has a passive recipient, too.
>> Tita Chico: Right.
>> You know.
>> That's with seduction.
So, I mean, it just, these
kind of influences of all
of these ideas at the time.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> And just the way seduction
can be taken in different ways,
so could experiential.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> And who is learning,
and who is authority,
and who is viewed could
be, you know, seen.
Which you think, too, we're
talking about seduction
and what is, when
we see it ourselves.
And then you have something
that's certainly not romance,
but for some reason,
I started thinking
about Defoe's Apparition of
Mrs. Veal, that his, you know,
the observation,
he's playing with us.
But, of course, we think
of this as a ghost story.
Or is it? Did she come back,
and what you can't attest to.
So, it just seems, and that's
totally a different discourse
that's going on on one side.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> This transformation
from seduction.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> But it's playing with some
of the same ideas,
minus the seduction.
So, I guess, I see, in a way,
what this seduction is in.
I'm not asking what
the seduction
and who has been supplying
with this seduction of that.
[ Background noise ]
>> Tita Chico: So, one of
the things that, I think,
it is also key to the way
that literary knowledge
and science operate is
that alongside this pedagogical
model, which is based
on pleasure, there are gestures,
and there are celebrations
of a version of what
you're talking about,
detailed observation.
Detailed observation
is at the core
of experimental knowledge
production.
And someone like Haywood, to go
back to the female spectator,
she is making an argument there,
particularly around the uses
of the microscope, and uses
of the scientific technology,
that this is a good practice,
specifically, for women,
and specifically, you
know, the main voice
of the female spectator
is a reformed coquette.
And, so, coquette is a
highly sexualized figure.
She's an epistemolant [assumed
spelling], she's a social
and ideological problem,
because she refuses to agree
to get married to anyone.
She's holding the moment
of courtship at abeyance.
But she's also a
problem of knowledge.
You can't know what
her heart is.
Okay? So, you can't know her.
She's an epistemological
problem.
So, Haywood takes that
figure, and reforms her.
That's her, that's the
female spectator is a
reformed coquette.
And, part of what the
use of, the praxis,
the artisanal experience
of science, can do,
is to help self improvement.
And a coquette, a reformed
coquette, is really good
at science, because
she knows how
to look closely and carefully.
All that experience
looking at clothing,
all that experience analyzing
society, all that experience,
kind of, that close examination.
So, she's an unlikely, but a
very pervasive examplar of a,
kind of, enlightened
scientific subjectivity
that becomes available
from this.
And, one of the things
that I really want to do,
to bring to this table, to the
table, is through this, kind of,
capacious archive that
I'm describing to you is
to think much more broadly
about scientific subjectivity.
And it's the ways in which
women have access to it
in different ways, and men have
access to it in different ways,
and different ranks,
and so forth.
So, the reformed
coquette, I think,
is just a remarkable
moment for her.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, let's thank Miss Chico
for a very interesting,
and enlightening.
>> Tita Chico: Yeah.
>> And the [inaudible]
have brought
out some very interesting
volumes
that we should take a moment to
have the opportunity to look at.
And anyone who wants
to come [inaudible]
after [inaudible] conversation.
>> Tita Chico: And can I say,
thank you all, it
was really nice.
Thank you.
Thanks so much.
[ Applause ]